hello welcome to another episode of not
too deep I'm your host grace Helbig
today we have a returning guest Megan
ranks is with us you might know her from
her podcast don't blame me from her
YouTube channel or maybe you've read her
new book you're not special we talked
about all of those things Megan so
lovely to talk to we get into the trials
and tribulations she had writing her
book which is fascinating and there were
lots of trials lots of tribulations we
also talked about the recent YouTube
drama she went through and where her
channel have been hacked and how
difficult it was to get any course of
action from the people at the top on
YouTube and I think it's a really
helpful conversation for people that
might be experiencing that in the social
media world or have the potential to
experience something like that she's got
a great insight on all the hardships
that she endured all while maintaining
the optimistic sarcastic layer of comedy
through it all so enjoy this episode of
not too deep with Megan ranks and go
read that book you're not special
how oblivion is that hell yeah megabanks
back on not too deep welcome back thanks
for having me of course of the many
things that you do this time around you
get to add author to that list that's so
exciting
I am currently rubbing it in my
boyfriend monstas face every day I'm
like what's it like to date an author
like and he was a creative writing major
in college so I'm like do you feel like
inadequate like I have a whole degree
and like I didn't even go to college
just being an [ __ ]
it comes with the territory now but okay
I've heard so much from Melissa about
the book writing experience process a
lot of it I want to hear from you
because this has been years in yeah
every book is you know years in the
making obviously but I feel like you've
had quite a roller coaster and getting
this product which is now officially out
in people's hands take us through the
roller coaster of the
journey of this book ah I mean a
rollercoaster is a great way to describe
it it's funny because I started I always
knew I wanted to write a book so I had
told my agents really early on and so I
was lucky so I people like how do you
sell a book I'm like I have no [ __ ]
idea guys like I I got we got to I got
to be one of those lucky people who gets
like approached for it but um it
literally what I went through to
publishers I went through giving back my
first advance to then finding a new
publisher and doing all of it
essentially all over again
Wow was insane and that's the stuff that
took like the longest like I think I
mean it definitely took me a while to
like write and edit but the stuff that
was the absolute longest process was me
being a complete and total hard-ass and
being like no I don't agree with any of
this
I'm not doing it throwing a tantrum yeah
and you know eventually getting my way
so moral of the story
if you complain enough they will cave in
but I think that that's really important
to recognize that like something fell
off something didn't feel right and
because a book I feel like is sometimes
way more intimate than like a video that
you post or a podcast that you post that
to have any sense of the it not feeling
right and being able to like speak up in
the moment of that and talk to people
especially that are professionals that
have been you know doing this longer
than you have it's hard to for me as
someone who doesn't like confrontation
in any capacity it's hard to recognize
that it's okay to like say no to
something I mean for you was that a
crazy process to be like I'm actually
gonna walk away and move and shift over
somewhere new so I'm the opposite I love
confrontation it is my drug I [ __ ]
live I love it I'm gonna outsource any
like issues that I have to you as my new
publicist to handle for me I will do it
I like confrontation when I'm in the
driver's seat and like I'm not a kind of
person like I'm never going to stand my
ground unless I'm a hundred percent sure
on something because like my track
record is like a hundred percent because
I will not dig my heels and if I'm even
a little bit unsure I'm like no I I'm
gonna be
so hardcore about it I'm really lucky
that I've had like the same manager
forever and so her and I are really
close and so a lot of the stuff was like
getting sill turd through her and she
knew I was like really upset
uncomfortable it's exactly what you said
where it was the book is so vulnerable
and writing a book is so vulnerable in
general my whole point was like I don't
feel safe like I don't [ __ ] safe in
your hands till I go out and do a book
tour and like present this whole thing
as like this is me this is great like
this is that I'm so [ __ ] proud of and
I was so not in my passive-aggressive
ass I literally forgot about this until
I was like cleaning up my computer I
then because it's a very giving back
your book advancements not like a thing
like that's not right really a thing
that people do and everybody discouraged
me like even my team who like I love and
we've talked about it since months when
you know when you write a book you're
spending so much one on like more
one-on-one time with your publisher than
everybody else is so you really know
versus like like word of mouth to
telling them and I just got to this
petty ass [ __ ] point where I just I
edited the book down from like it was
like 350 pages I edited it down to
thirty of all of the most like surface
level nothing deep nothing intense and
then I edited everything to have like a
happy ending because that's what they
wanted even though it wasn't like real
and then they also like they didn't like
the name so then I combined every they
gave me a list of 30 names which were
all awful and then I combined all of
them and then I made that the new title
page and then I said a book about Megan
ranks and I they never received it I
sent it to my manager and she goes
message received loud and clear we will
give the book advance back she's like I
can't send this to them and I was like
well this is what I - Wow I mean yeah
that sometimes you really have to
present things in a dramatic way for
people to understand where you're coming
from because you know business side of
stuff people don't have the emotional
investment that you have in the work
itself so you have to kind of shake
people sometimes and be like this this
is my this is how I'm feeling
it will on a more broad level how do you
describe the book to people I describe
it as like a if your best friend wrote a
self-help book who like dropped out of
college and like doesn't have a
psychology degree so it's like not
necessarily the best advice you'd ever
get but it it really is honestly like
the inspiration for my podcast was based
off of this it's giving advice but all
of the advice is qualified by oh god my
hair look listen to this funny story
that happened to me or like until like
my own personal experience with this and
then I'm kind of giving you advice
through it so I have had people who are
like it's a sort of memoirs any part
fiction I don't know I mean it sound
like a real memoirs like I haven't like
done anything like that right revolution
is so like that's why it's a sort of
mark it's like I'm not that confident
but yeah I think it's it very much
from I mean I obviously can't like read
it as someone who's not me but from what
I've heard from everybody else it
literally just sounds like me and it
sounds like you're talking to a friend
which i think is a much more
approachable take to self-help because I
I'm like there are like professionals
and people with PhD is that I like
definitely like want you know like
drawing I don't know like giving me
anesthesia and like all of that stuff
like okay but then there's some times
where I'm like this is like you went to
school for all of these years and this
is everything you learned so I'm
supposed to learn it in like 300 pages
like I don't think that's gonna be valid
for me so it's a it's a little a mix of
of memoir and then self-help cool and so
on a level from like completely not
personal to like airing out every piece
of dirty laundry you have where does the
intimacy fall I would say that I
probably have two pieces of dirty
laundry left that's it I would say that
I only have probably yeah like two I
mean it's it gets very personal but to
like a constructive point and I think
that's something that I'm glad that it's
coming out when I'm a little bit older
like I'm only 26 but like when I first
started writing it I was like
- right and there's a lot of like anger
and you're [ __ ] pissed and like
you're getting your feelings all out and
I was like okay this is like a journal
and like you need to simmer it down and
like come up with like something
constructive for people to take away
from the story I think it it's a it
doesn't I hope it doesn't feel as much
like word vomit as it does of like oh
look at these things that I've been
through and like this is how I've
processed right but it's personal that's
good oh because I think that's at least
for me when I first discovered you
online through your whole you know the
cosmetic surgery there the nose job I
it's so fascinating because you were so
transparent about everything and just
like the gross data in and day out of
like this is what happens when you get a
nose job
unapologetically in a way and so there
is I think for your audience is super
fascination with like the life you've
you've led and to know that you've done
so much work on yourself personally to
be able to like you said have processed
all these things and come out with like
an understanding to present to people
rather than like here's some crazy [ __ ]
that happened to me
isn't that crazy and that instead being
like that was crazy but here's like the
things the major takeaways that can
probably affect your life differently
did you have did you talk to your family
throughout the creative process of it no
um so the I think that's the thing that
everybody I mean literally everyone from
my like [ __ ] home town was like I
bought the book and I skip straight to
the chapter about your parents like
[ __ ] you know me like why like yo this
story there's like no I just like wanted
to see like what version was in the book
so yeah I mean it's I I start the
chapter about my parents and so arts so
that's the chapter that everybody I
would say is like them was the most
wanting to hear because it went from
like especially if you said the nose job
videos like you were seeing all of my
life and like my family in it and then
it kind of went radio silent and people
had a lot of questions and I think
people who watch my videos regularly
could also see that I really pull
back from my personal life so like I
started dating my boyfriend moths around
that same time I didn't show him on
camera for a year didn't show my parents
on camera wasn't showing my friends on
camera like everything was like so
people at before had seen me be like so
personal and then really take a step
back so I think everyone was like what's
it gonna be all right
oh yeah you basically you took a curtain
and you went yos and everyone's like
wait what's behind the curtain now why
is the curtain closed and I'm sure the
amount of assumptions that happen from
everyone based off of that must have
been so overwhelming yeah I mean it
definitely was really really really hard
when I when it break first kind of
started and like I was like pulling
everything back because it was like you
know a way fresher kind of wound and I
was like still processing all of it and
I am so glad that like the book has come
out and that chapter specifically has
come out when I'm in such a different
[ __ ] headspace and like so like you
I'm just I'm removed from it in a way
that I think is so much more productive
for people to read but yeah I mean
people will if they've read it they will
have seen but it definitely I even
started writing the book before all of
the [ __ ] like happened with like weird
like the [ __ ] that like really hits the
fan in that chapter before that happened
so I literally start the chapter being
like well didn't think I was gonna write
this one and I was like what at least
but as it was happening my best friend
kept be like well like at least you're
writing a book yeah it's like there's
almost like a rationalization for a
trauma experience because now it can
become a creative content no that's how
my mind when I was like okay cool like
let's actually like get some [ __ ] use
out of this [ __ ] I totally do you have a
favorite part of the book would you say
it's that part or is there something
else that sticks out to you so I think
that I mean I think the one that I had
the most fun writing because I like to
write I just yeah also hate it you know
like oh yeah the physicality of sitting
down and and like singularly focusing on
writing because I think we're similar in
that like I have to be doing multiple
things at once or I like I feel strange
or like non-productive and writing you
can't you can't do that no and then you
would write like five pages that go well
that sucks but I'm in the groove now so
I'm gonna delete all of that and then
like start this chapter again yeah so
but so I would say the one that was the
most fun for me to write is I have a
chapter called my date with a GDI and
it's like the worst date ever
and if you did you go to a school with
sororities and fraternities
yes but it was such it was such small
potatoes that it was like see it was
like the generic version of sororities
and fraternities so we used to call the
people who weren't affiliated in
sororities and fraternities GD Eyes
goddamn independence and he was like the
Gd I went on a date with and that was
probably the most fun for me too right
because like you were saying those
experiences we were like I need to like
it feels like that whole [ __ ] story
feels like when you eat [ __ ] and nobody
else sees and you're like I needed
somebody else this is so embarrassing
and so bad and like you're like laughing
and kind of crying but you're right I
need someone else in this with me that
whole experience like in that whole date
felt like and I just remember like that
whole night being like well I was like
why and so it felt really nice to kind
of write about it and I didn't know that
anybody else would have that feeling cuz
it's kind of like oh did you have to be
there like is it that interesting but I
would say out of all of the chapters
that aren't like the more like emotional
ones that people have been relating to
like everybody's been like dude that
[ __ ] one like [ __ ] that Nathan dude
like that's insane okay cool it's like
it was [ __ ] insane probably my
favorite oh that's so exciting and
obviously very makes me want to read it
immediately did you have to awkwardly
get permissions from people that you
were mentioning in the book so the first
draft that I wrote I wrote everyone's
real names just because like it's so
much easier for me to keep it straight
yeah and so now my friends will like
reference like certain or
even like like like people who've read
it will reference certain characters
like I have no idea who you're talking
okay changed all of the names like that
was the last thing that I did so I'm
like I don't know who that is so I made
a master list on my phone and I sent it
to all of like my home friends so they
could like keep track but the only
people whose names I used their real
names I used a couple of kids from high
school I used one kid from high school
his first and last name just because
like he's got he the first elasti oh and
he only gets like to shout outs but
they're both like funny that I'm saying
his full name right and it's all
positive so I like asked him and he was
like oh for sure oh by the book and then
the my best friend Sydney her name is
her name and then my best friend one of
my other best friends his twin brother
him and I dated we were in seventh grade
and I asked him we don't talk anymore
cuz you know rough breakup sevens great
and I like asked his twin who's my best
friend to ask him and he was as long as
it's not defamatory and I was like what
does he think I'm gonna say about
doesn't even have a whole chapter he has
like a small reference right I wanted to
keep like if I could keep like any
little references of real people's names
like that's more like Easter Egg for me
sure only probably only five names that
are real and then everybody else I
changed because you have to technically
you write about you that they like
legally get permission from everyone you
don't even have it's just to be nice you
just don't really them a heads up yeah I
thought you had to legally get
permission in case they could see you if
they found something like you said to
fam'ly Tori so it's I've learned a lot
about to sandwich very cases bleeding
out try book there's it's there's really
no money in a defamatory case and so the
only time that you actually sue for
defamation is like if you're a celebrity
or an actor and you sue a publication
for printing something wrong and then
you can prove you lost out on a job
because of said art gotcha gosh so it's
not but I also was just like I love
confrontation but like I don't want
anyone who's in the book and a negative
light to be like hello right and then it
creates a story for the second book
exactly perfect okay we're gonna take a
quick break we get back
I have to ask you all about this journey
of your channel being hacked because I
think there's probably a lot for people
that are content creators and want to be
content creators to learn from your
experience which is the theme learning
through Megan's experiences okay we'll
be right back with more not too deep are
you thinking about quitting drinking but
you're not sure where to start if
alcohol is no longer helping you live
the life that you want now is the time
to try something new and Tempest is a
digital recovery program that can help
you stop drinking and feel better they
offer three annual membership plans
based on the level of care you need and
how much time you'd like to commit each
plan is designed to support you wherever
you are on your recovery journey whether
you're still drinking or you've already
got some experience with sobriety their
membership plans help you learn healthy
habits discover new coping mechanisms
and get connected with a community of
folks who are going through the same
thing and with virtual support meetings
weekly lessons live lectures and
educational resources tempest can help
you change a relationship with alcohol
forever
tempest isn't just about quitting
drinking it's about building a life that
you don't need to escape from so visit
join Tempest dot-com to learn more and
use code grace to get $50 off any
membership option you choose that's
tempest calm TEM PST dot-com and use the
code grace for $50 off let's talk about
the your channel because I feel like
you're just a person that loves to go on
journeys like this I should go on The
Bachelor I know right I feel like you
should have like such travel miles
because you've been on so many journeys
this this whole catastrophe debacle with
the hacking of your channel for people
that don't know about this can you
explain a little bit or as much as you
want about this so I don't even I think
it was last
in October I had gotten a attempt to
hack my main channel and I am not
confident about a lot of things but I'm
very confident about my security and
also about my internet sleuthing
abilities so I was able to like get that
person out they unsuccessfully got into
my didn't get into my they were
unsuccessful in getting into my channel
okay and then I started to filed a claim
with YouTube just to make sure even
though they never got in and taking all
the right precautions huh oh I'm all
about precautions and my videos were
just like suddenly they were uploaded
but you couldn't see them on my channel
and so it was like a very obvious seemed
like a really easy thing to me that I
was like I mean like all of my brand
like my channel artwork is still there
everything's still there like you can
search my videos but they're just like
not on my showing up on my channel so
like that feels weird you can get to it
from a direct link
I thought it was gonna be really simple
and like fixed really quickly and took
like a month or so for lots of like no
nothing's wrong everything's fine and
like well you don't see what you're
talking about yeah this is a crazy thing
because I think a lot of people that
obviously haven't had any difficulties
with YouTube and see it as this
completely fully functional platform
this is really important for people to
hear because you're not new to this
platform you've been using it for like
how many days 10 years at this point and
you've provided a lot in terms of you
know for the content for the platform on
behalf of just being an independent
content creator and the immediate
inability for them to hear and recognize
a problem with you is so important for
people to hear about because I think a
lot of people still live in this
blissful ignorance that the platform is
perfect yeah and I think I was
definitely guilty of I will fully admit
that I know I think I knew that the
platform wasn't perfect but like kind of
in that [ __ ] way of like well that
that wouldn't necessarily apply to me
because like I I have like a manager I
have agents I have
access that I can kind of surpass the
system that's built there and I
understand that like you can't deal like
a platform that's that big they can't
deal with every single complaint of
every single channel I'm like they're
gonna invest their time and the ones
that are making them money is that the
like if we're talking about like the
greatest morals like in the world no but
like also they're a profitable business
and so then I was like wait so if this
is what's happening to me what is
happening to the channels in my mind
that I thought would be getting the
treatment that I was getting not that I
thought I deserved it again but just
more long lines thinking of it like a
business
well you I was never you had never had
to really think about this they say the
same for me is that I have a lot of
content creator friends that are very
involved in the reform that needs to
happen on the YouTube platform and I am
you know for better or worse mostly
worse not as active in that arena
because I have never firsthand had to
deal with this kind of [ __ ] and so once
you're faced with this and then all
sudden you're like I'm knocking at the
door and I can see someone's home and no
one's coming to the door what's going
yeah that you're like seeing them close
their curtains and you know you're home
what's going on it's literally the exact
exact feeling that I had and it was one
of those things where everything just
kept getting worse and I kept giving
them the benefit of the doubt because
like they're this massive company and
like they'll figure they've got it
figured out I'm not gonna question their
process because like I'm not a coder I
like don't know how this kind of stuff
works and really what I've learned over
the course of my life is like I
definitely am glad I dropped out of
college because I think I could have any
job that I want like I had like I'm like
I could be a editor I could be a
publisher and I could do that but yeah
it was it was a wild journey that I
don't even I have like Lily Lily Marston
to think for so much of it because
because she was on the outside she was
like she was being like Claire Danes
from homeland and putting all of the
little strings together where I was very
living in it so I wasn't kind of seeing
the bigger picture or seeing how
ridiculous it was and she was talking to
her other friends were creators and all
of this kind of stuff and
he was the one who was like dude this is
something and this is something so much
bigger than you this is something that's
like you have to make a video about this
this is not normal like this is so crazy
and so bad and it ate like and we didn't
even I didn't even research or go
through the emails or make a timeline or
do anything until the day that I filmed
part one and like I'm so heated in part
one and that's because I just realized
that like how [ __ ] crazy it all was I
was like oh my god like actually you're
not noticed I'm very mad about this yes
I went from being like they've got it
too big they clearly do not have it they
do not have this covered at all
uh-huh and that's a that's such a
strange feeling to be like this thing
that I kind of didn't realize I was
blindly trusting it doesn't work for me
and my only option is just scream out
loud about it and let people know what's
going on and so so Lilly hope you make
this video that like explained very
openly to people what was going on which
i think is great because yeah what are
your options at that point as I was I
was completely lost at what to do and a
lot of other like youtubers were
retweeting because I think it like like
you say it's a really [ __ ] scary like
it's like Gigi Hadid get in on this yeah
so special you know you [ __ ] up when a
head he goes what's happening over here
so she DM me and she's followed me
she watched my nose job series and so
and I've met her before she's so nice
very sweet and she deemed me and she has
a contact at YouTube which her contact
at YouTube not gonna say who were
contact at YouTube is explicitly but it
is someone who this is like so so so
below their pay grade like they like
they like really I was like oh god are
you sure and they gave me their like
personal like phone number and email
address to then contact them and they
were like completely floored and all of
that stuff too but I think the stuff
that was the craziest to me was what
happened between part one and like
- was that I thought part I thought we
didn't need a part one like I I mean I
thought part one was gonna be it like I
thought I make this video it all gets
figured out and then it became even
worse and it became like even more
silence and even more like not about any
of that stuff so it was it was I got I
remember and I had so many auditions
that like same week and they just like
kept being like hey we can get on a
phone call in five minutes it was like I
was I literally need Botox from it it
was so stressful
wait so what happened in between were
they reaching out trying to rectify or
were they still ignoring the problem so
it was a lot of it was a lot of like I I
someone had reached out eventually but I
was still emailing them like and then
finally someone then responded like a
couple of days after the video was up
and it was a lot of me chasing them down
to have a conversation and it was a lot
of those are great questions we have a
conversation have a phone call and then
we'll get back to you tomorrow and not
getting back to me tomorrow not the next
day not the next day and then me
emailing every single day and nothing it
felt like it was moving slower than
before and then I got chained texted it
literally it starts and ends with Shane
and Shane texted Lily and Shane has a
contact at YouTube who all live I mean
all of YouTube it's all my video hey-oh
had seen it I was like well they have to
at that point because it's like it might
seem trivial or frivolous or like you
know self-centered in some way and
superficial to be like what about me and
my channel but the broader issue is that
if this smaller thing doesn't get
rectified how can this potentially
steamroll into really harmful [ __ ] on
the platform that becomes impossible for
them to rectify because they only have
so much means of doing so know exactly
like ages made me feel like
oh [ __ ] like what else has happened like
what like what else is gonna happen yeah
but Shane's YouTube contact wanted to
like speak to me directly and we talked
and they were like I was like why
haven't I spoken to you since the
beginning
thank you makes so much sense you are
smart and like you're being like hey we
like hella [ __ ] up and I was like
thank you but all I needed that's
literally open I'm not crazy you guys
acknowledge this thank you that's like
what all I really really wanted and I
got a lot of heat from my friend like
the third video that I did where's like
the conclusion that was like I'm not
getting my videos back it sucked I got
some explanations I got some
explanations about stuff that I have to
remain confidential about but it's not
helpful to like any other creator it's
more what specifically went wrong in my
case and they're fixing it but if I say
what exactly went wrong it can happen
like if I've been giving someone the
blueprints to do it again right marry
working on it and is that blind trust
sure but do I have to have blind trust
otherwise I will literally go insane
yeah and I think people like the pile-on
of like cancel expose and I am all about
like doing your research deep-diving
internet sleuthing and all of that sort
of stuff but it gets to a certain point
where when you're just consuming that is
entertainment and you're being like you
have to sue you have to sue and I'm like
would you just like to Google how much
it would cost yes yeah only in dollar
company that's like Google like haha
think about like there isn't nobody is
going to feel like it's on a movie and I
think people kind of want that like come
up it's like moments and I'm like life's
just not like that sometimes and laughs
you get tired like you get tired when
you're that angry all of the time Oh
exactly and it's like you have to at
some point see the realistic see the
reality of it versus the movie version
of it and say what's like the
cost-benefit here to you know make this
more dramatic or is this you know the
best solution for me at this point but I
think that's I mean you're always that
it's crazy right here and no matter what
you do you're damned if you do damned if
you don't
putting anything out
there people are gonna be upset with how
you handle or present anything all the
time and sometimes it just makes you
want to crawl in a hole and not do
anything what fun we were also talking
about your podcast don't blame me which
you guys have apparently Melissa found
out right before the year you've done
125 episodes oh my god
yeah isn't that that hell that's insane
it's really crazy
is there something or some things that
you've learned the most over how many
years have you guys been doing this a
few years yeah a few years I've learned
a lot which is while because I don't
think I really even think about it in
that sense of like Oh what have I like
learned from the podcast but when I was
doing edits of my book like the last
round of edits I was recognizing that a
lot of like the things I was updating or
kind of like refining were things that I
kind of learned through the podcast I
was like oh wow this is better than
school this is like yeah I think
something that's I don't know I think
one thing that has changed not
necessarily changed a lot but I think
I'm like more aware of how I say things
to like be constructive and not net like
not try I mean out try to hurt someone's
feelings but I like to think of myself
I'm very very blunt and I am like the
friend that you come to when you want
you're not I'm not gonna sugarcoat it
I'm gonna be honest with you but I think
I've like learned how to be more
constructive in that and kind of
recognize I also usually really like
when our callers will let us know if
they are a water sign specifically if
they are a cancer or a Pisces so I know
I can be easy on them or they'll be like
I'm PMSing I'm like great cool I needed
to know that because like they're like
please just like be nice to me like that
side like I as long as you let me know
ahead of time uh-huh any other like I
think there's just a lot of like
relationship stuff to like the more that
a huge but majority of the conversations
and like advice questions that will get
will pertain to relationships and I
think that I'm learning a lot more about
other people's lives that are like in
other walks of life that are different
than my
own and different than like the things
that my friends experience and then I
think it's interesting too because then
we don't know necessarily what life
experiences we have coming up so like
we've done episodes of the podcast where
we've given advice and then like it
happens in my life or whatever and I'm
like oh so am I gonna take my own advice
like so what's gonna happen there but
yeah I think it's I think it's cool too
because we have people will they'll call
back in and give us updates or that's
cool and then we get to see like they're
kind of growth - and I think if it's
been like a long period of time - we can
kind of see it differently and then be
like oh wow this did work out how we
thought or it didn't work out but it's
that and then also that majority of men
are trash is the other thing that I've
learned Wow some of these girls have the
[ __ ] work they date they date some
shitty dudes some shitty shitty dudes
well I mean the good thing is to not
you no longer have the assumption you
have the actual proof of the potential
shittiness of men and the experiences
and how they've unfolded to be able to
back up that that said you and Melissa
have been working together for a while
now do you think that you guys would
succeed on the Amazing Race
Wow that is a very good question I think
we would if I was given a new stomach
and new legs okay but I think Melissa
has everything that it takes to be on
The Amazing Race yeah I might Alyssa
went you would succeed regardless of
partner he could do it alone
yeah she could fully do I I think that
my only hold up is I definitely would
hold her back and drag her down so I
think if I got a stomach transplant and
then new legs so I could like run and
have better knees and ankles I think I
would be a good a good candidate nice
are there any reality shows they in the
in the legs that you have now and with
the stomach you have now that you think
you had thrive in Oh The Bachelor okay I
but a small small times like would you
let me go
music well they would know you're
[ __ ] with them but he has full he's
like no you talk like I think I would
crush it like I would be your first of
all what would be your entrance have you
thought about how you would introduce
yourself to the bachelor I think my
entrance would be it wouldn't be sexual
because like Rose they just don't
if they think the producers give you a
sexual one and they're like they're
gonna put like that like wah-wah music
in the background and like you're good
they're making fun of you yeah so I
think I would either do something like I
would either do something like a really
simple or give them I think I'd probably
give them a little thing like look at
this like this little token stupid and
sure whatever's related Slyke the toggle
and if you're seasoned like like but I
would just be the whole thing that I and
I mean I'm like I'm revealing what I
think the secret is is that like I these
in the show in general it's everybody's
like fighting for and specifically for
the bachelor because I think the
bachelorettes totally different okay I
think women are really great at like you
know
sifting out and picking the dudes that
they like but the other for the bachelor
it's my whole tactic would be make him
want to date me as a host to like oh I
really want to date you and the ones who
do the best are the girls that like make
them work for it but in a really like
not an obvious way not like a it's like
no it's like come over here and it's
like stop it like we see see through
that it would be like that I'm not like
other girls but I would never say that
because that is a telltale sign you are
like the other girls yep yeah and
there's nothing wrong with the other
girls and so I would just really come at
it from like the like oh my god my
friend signed me up like I don't know
like who knows whatever be fair that
tactic is very much like Kelly from
Peter season and then Kelly got sent
home but that's also because Peter Peter
is like Caillou he's like a giant baby
some mommy issues going there I didn't
watch his season because it seemed a
little from the gecko a little like I
don't think this is right I don't think
he's like got all the emotional tools in
his emotional toolbox to make a decision
that I as an adult could get behind you
should watch his tick-tock oh he's got a
tick-tock he's got a tick-tock
is he good at it um if the goal is
laughter he's fantastic
oh but I'm also like I loved Mike FRA
whose season was that
Hanabi I loved Mike he was like so sweet
he's like he's I've wanted Mike like my
queen like all about that oh and then I
also like every every person every
whatever you are anybody would [ __ ]
Tyler Cameron and that was my other like
sir yes sir you can respect me any day
Wow I'm here to help you with your I
think I'll respect your boundaries it's
not like please don't respect my back I
have no boundaries of you Wow
well he's playing the game I think that
you've described for yourself that like
make make someone else want to pursue
you yes that sense of like aloofness
that like quiet confidence of like I
don't need to be all over you and I
don't need to be paranoid in this
situation that puts people that makes
people uneasy when you're just like yeah
I'm here I'm not dramatic I know exactly
what's going on I know exactly who I am
and I'll get ahead of the way that they
potentially want to edit me it'll be
correctly but it has to be you have to
do that for a bachelor who's confident
it happy like a bachelor who's like no I
think I need I need the attention and
like the reassurance yeah I'd be like
I'm sending myself home no exactly I
want to be the person that would meet
him right away and go yeah no not for me
but thank you is so nice to be here I'm
gonna have a couple drinks and I'm
probably gonna head out but like a good
night
enjoy enjoy your journey baking baking
you've this whole other side of you that
is you know it it's all falls under the
Megane umbrella but it feels like a
little bit of a divergent side from all
of the self-help stuff baking is a major
hobby for you it is I refer to my brand
as mommy bloggers without child that's
great because I that's what I'm like I
started to come up with potential shows
to pitch you and one of it this is all
very very in the beginning stages of
ideas is called prove it where it's like
you proving bread but like while it's
proving you bring on an expert to come
and prove some sort of like
socio-economic injustice and how people
can help can it be me and Bill Nye I
think that'd be great I mean that that's
a collab that ml Gore oh my god that's a
trio there you go
for you what is bait why how did you
find yourself into this world so much
because it feels so much more like the
the podcast in the book you're it's
almost like a controlled messiness you
know and then baking is very precise
that is it just like a different side of
your brain that needs that thing kind of
fed it's also a controlled messiness but
it feeds into it's like me doing my new
hobby as puzzles yeah yeah it feeds into
my or it's not feeds into but it caters
really well it's like my ADHD brain so
it is a lot of oh I can't necessarily
mess this up and it has I have to be
precise and I have to really think about
it and that's something that I'm not
like I am NOT like that like I am an
elephant in a china shop like I am NOT
Delic I've never been delicate I've
never been dainty like I am just kind of
a tornado and baking is something that
forces me to not be that like I'm a type
a tornado though too so it's kind of
like I'm upset I'm like but like in a
very messy way control this but I got
into it when I was in I mean I always
loved watching the Food Network like
that was like my like guilty I mean not
anything guilty I in a garden is my
queen yeah obsessed for so long and then
in college when I like had no friends I
was making like dinner and like cooking
for myself alone and so it was a lot
more like Oh scrolling through Pinterest
finding recipes and then the more that I
just kind of like lived alone and I had
to cook for myself I realized that like
you know savory food is like it's not
that pretty and like it's definitely
cute
is fun yeah it also is you can kind of
like throw it all around and whoever
hairs and then I got more into baking
shows and then just got really into
baking I think I was fascinated by it
like I loved going to pastry shops as a
kid and just like looking at how pretty
everything was yes so I definitely liked
it from like an aesthetic standpoint of
like yeah fun and pretty yeah it's it's
all the benefits of cooking with the
added focus and emphasis on aesthetic
mm-hmm love an aesthetic of course look
at your Instagram the have you ever
thought about opening a bakery I think
that I would be I think it'd be like fun
to do like a like a temporary pop I mean
in my dream I would open like in a Nancy
Meyers movie like I am Diane Keaton and
it's beautiful and it looks like
restoration hard and I'm there with my
turtleneck and like my burlap apron I
love that image I've also heard like the
restaurant business and like is like
very intense but maybe bakeries would be
less intense I think I would be I think
I would honestly thrive running like a
bakery in Napa like or like the Hamptons
like I could just become ina I would
enjoy that but that's what I see like I
don't see myself doing it I only see
myself doing it with like white hair
like I always see it as like a kind to
elderly lady yeah I don't want to be
like that what's that like 20 30 year
old doing in this bakery like I want
like oh that's sweet older woman
I wonder how her children are doing in
college I want to look wholesome as hell
I think you can get there okay we're
gonna take one last break and then we'll
wrap it up here on not too deep we'll be
right back
[Music]
too deep with playside back
you
well we're getting towards the end of
the podcast Megan and I'm gonna ask you
the two questions that you've answered
before on the podcast that every guest
gets to answer and the first is who are
alive or dead
alive or dead would you most like to
throw cold spaghetti at fortune
spaghetti it can be right right now that
is such a loaded question because like
the names off the top of my head there
are so many it's a Rolodex yeah I would
probably say I don't know I've been
thinking about Condoleezza Rice a lot
and I just like I just I wonder how
she'd react mmm yeah I don't know that
we've had that answer yet so that's a
new one for us she's been on my mind for
literally no reason like she's just a
name that keeps popping into my head so
I would be I would just be I think I'd
be more along the lines like I want to
know what she's doing and then the
spaghetti is a vehicle to like you know
see where she's at in her life like this
conversation exactly okay the other
question is to tell us your worst pants
[ __ ] story or a close call but you
can only use three words or three small
phrases so mine is college jog jog on
front lawn yeah
I gotta get an updated one there have
been so many I don't know why I just
repress them so quickly now um to be
honest I don't know if I've had any
other like recent ones why also have IBS
so like I know the signs before they
happen and I'm that's good let's get to
this bathroom probably close call would
be I think maybe I did this the last
time traffic nail salon hmm close call
love it love it love it love it I also
love that your boyfriend's getting
something have a fridge in the back
what's up I know we can just see you so
perfectly in frame right over your
shoulder it's great Megan thank you for
coming back and talking to us about all
the new updates in your world it's very
exciting
usually in person we provide our guests
a gift a personalized fortune cookie but
now we are doing some digital
fortune cookies I believe Melissa sent
you if you'd like to read your personal
fortune cookie out loud let's see my
really secure really is fast Wi-Fi I
mean the Wi-Fi is secure and then we
find out that you've just been hacked 17
times because we've talked about it
since podcasts oh my god I'm like is
this like karma what I'm finally getting
okay fortune cookie
I'm opening humans are the only animal
whose brains shrink but we have a
feeling you already knew that
Wow was that true it was written down so
it must be true and how it works and the
way that all of us operate now no use in
doing our own research to find out facts
for ourselves you should use this for
another episode but that uh kangaroos I
think the male kangaroos have like three
penises and the female kangaroos have
like two vaginas yeah I've heard
something like that I also recently
found out that koalas will sometimes the
female so may it like have orgies and
they last longer than the male female
sexual intercourse yeah well I mean
check citrus nature's crazy making bacon
people listen to the podcast get the
book and everything that you're up to if
they don't know the podcast is available
wherever you listen to podcasts Apple
Spotify stitcher we also do video
versions on YouTube if you ever want to
see Melissa and I our faces as I like
gasp and my book is available wherever
books are oh I did an audiobook that is
available everywhere as well as the
hardcover and then the kindle version
but oh yeah people just have to google
where their country is because the
amount of times I've had to explain to
people who are in Canada for like it's
not our Amazon I'm like are you on
Amazon Canada they're like no yes also
the caveat for everyone to have some
sensitivities about the delivery
schedule of everything as of Lakes I
know that there was some issues with
that because
the way the world is right now yes so I
know a lot of people got in which I'm
flattered got impatient and either did
audiobook and or like digital one and
then they're like and then I have the
hardcover as a coffee table book that's
like I love it it's great the aesthetics
make it a perfect decoration for your
home oh I tried I love it Thank You
Megan for being here this was so fun
good luck it's writing me the recording
an episode of don't blame me right after
this so guys go listen to don't blame me
and we'll see you next time on another
episode of not too deep goodbye 2deep
2deep 2deep 2deep not too deep is a
production of grace helbig incorporated
producer Melissa D months edited by
Shireen Lonnie Eunice post-production
sound by Chris Henry and an extra
special thanks to Flula for the theme
music
[Music]